et chansonnettes et
la tête sur un air d'accordéon
ce qu'il ya dans tes mirettes qu'il veut
tourner la tête
c'est là
alors on va y a pas c'est vous pourtant
être habitué c'est pas une obsession
tous ces mots de ces phases macra tant
chanté montant une fois le matin moisan
je chante haut de la journée alors vous
qui vivez avec lui oui mais moi j'aime
bien me refera pas vivre à ce moment
pour lui oui oui suivait dans tous ses
voyages
chaque fois que je peux oui c'est vrai
d'enfants on est tellement habitué à
vous voir ensemble si on a oublié à quel
point vous étiez unis d'assez rare est
ce que par hasard vous aimeriez sait
mais on s'aime bien on s'aime bien et en
scène revenons revenons au cinéma votre
carrière six mois de signaux est assez
étrange parce que depuis quelques temps
la plupart des films vous avez faits ont
été produits réalisés à l'étranger
j'ai tourné au mexique et en allemagne
ça sert de salam news la laine français
l'essentiel oui mais bien sûr mais ça se
passait quand même à l'étranger
et maintenant vous arrivez à cannes
comme vedette anglaise que moi ce que
vous expliquez cela je ne sais pas
l'expliquer je crois que c'est vrai
qu'il va tomber en france depuis
longtemps j'ai tourné ce film anglais
parce que on m'a proposé une très bonne
histoire et que j'ai eu envie de la
faire mais les français vont à proposer
la même histoire je leur ai tourné aussi
volontiers mais je vous donnais paroles
françaises dans ce fut 6 à 7 à la
française de demain en français
moi je parie qu'on avait été jusqu'au
jusqu'au bout de la voiture non non
c'est à dire que dans le roman n'est pas
française mais comme elle est d'ailleurs
c'est pas un personnage qui appartient
qui appartient au milieu qu'on décrit
elle est un élément étranger alors ils
ont pu la transformer en française pour
cette treizième le film s'appelle
mohamed tap
ils ont traduit ça de façon très simple
ils ont tatoué ça va c'était très
difficile à traduire parce que enfants
en anglais c'est un ca de sens à ça le
sens d'une chambre qui est en haut et ça
aussi le charme le sens du daim d'une
place dans la société qui étend le titre
est merveilleux utt une place au soleil
et un thé pris part à mon fils même
assez bien pris d'ailleurs vous appelle
les chemins de la haute ville louis
attendant mieux
france est une histoire qu'a eu
énormément de succès à l'angleterre je
crois que le film marche également très
bien en amérique
oui le roman alors le roman a eu
beaucoup de succès en angleterre il ya
deux ans mai dernier le film a très bien
marché en angleterre il marche très bien
numérique quelles sont vos impressions
de vedettes anglaises à cannes je suis
pas une vedette alors je n'ai pas
d'impression de vedettes ni anglais ni
française parce que je me sens pas dans
la dans la peau de de ce que vous avez
dit je ne me sens pas dans la peau d'une
ve d'assises est une vedette
j'ai probablement pas là aujourd'hui
comme je suis c'est à dire de mieux
serait un petit peu mieux a rangé comme
je suis fatigué qui n'est pas très
bonnes minutes ne seraient peut-être
arrangé pour vous demander de faire ça
une autre fois où j'aurais été me
relaxer pendant trois heures avant de
venir
c'est ça une vedette d'une vedette c'est
très difficile je crois d'être une
vedette
j'ai pas du tout 2 j'ai pas du tout de
mépris qu'ont certaines comédiennes pour
ce qu'on appelle les grandes vedettes je
pense que pour être vraiment une très
grande vedette comme est par exemple
nombreux dida ou sophia loren ou les
grosses vedettes américaines je crois
que c'est un travail de tous les
instants a enfin dû du matin quand on se
réveille jusqu'au soir où on se couche
c'est un métier qui ne vous permet pas
la moindre distraction ni dans la façon
dont on doit s'habiller dans la façon
dont on va se comporter ni dans la façon
dont on doit être vis-à-vis des gens moi
je serai pas le faire je je je crois que
c'est très difficile et je ne saurais
pas je ne saurais pas le faire bien
cette spécialité
c'est un métier qui s'apprend du roi et
vous voulez vous permettre de
distraction est oui d'ailleurs vous le
permettez également dans le choix des
films que vous tournez pas ce que vous
tournez assez peu parce que voulait
tourner librement les choses qui vous
intéressent oui un avantage et un
désavantage
oui il faut dire que j'ai enfin je peux
me permettre ça j'ai une position que je
qualifierais de luxe parce que les deux
et que que je si j'étais seul dans la
vie si j'étais pas mariée à mon temps et
si j'ai besoin de souvenirs à mes
propres besoins
des levés par exemple mon enfant seule
comme certaines filles que je connais je
pourrais pas me permettre de ne faire qu
affine toulouse